but let's get back to your
superposition argument we all agree that
it's going to be a superposition that's
not the interesting you know if it could
be Iran or it could be China that's a
superposition of different explanations
no one says that all drones have to come
from one country
the key issue isn't superpositions of
different mundane categories the key
issue is is there anything at the moment
that argues in your mind
for an exotic explanation time traveling
humans visitors from another galaxy
etc etc
not in my mind no and uh I I'm curious
as to
why people individual people that's part
of my interest actually is is trying to
figure out why people believe uh what
they what they believe why do people
believe weird things why do people think
that time traveling uh humans from the
future is actually a reasonable
explanation why do they think that uh
trickster Spirits is is a reasonable
explanation I know there's some fairly
serious people who use the term
trickster uh as uh uh a kind of an
explanation for UFOs there's some kind
of trickster From Another Dimension who
has come over you know Jack valet I
think is a big proponent of this and uh
his his uh his colleague uh I forget his
name now at uh uh that they they talk
about tricksters what is it that
actually makes people who are at one
point serious scientists go over to
thinking that uh essentially
poltergeists from outer space is a
reasonable explanation to things now I
don't say that that's to I mean that
sounds like I'm mocking them but that's
exactly the type of things they do it
does sound like I'm mocking them yes I
know but uh that's an unfortunate look I
don't want to trap you and Mick I don't
trap you in language if it sounds that
way to you it's just real quick it's
real quick I want to address that point
like I'm not mocking them I'm
essentially trying to accurately
describe their positions and it's
unfortunate that uh with a lot of these
things if you talk about say Flat Earth
if you try to describe the position it
comes across as ridiculous uh when
someone is is using tricksters From
Another Dimension as an explanation for
UFOs it comes across as ridiculous but
it's actually what they say
let's try this carefully
let me imagine
that you and I are living on North
Sentinel Island uh in the Andaman chain
in in the Indian Ocean
and
I say you know I can't help but feel
that there's a bigger world out there
and that every time something tries to
contact us there's a force an unseen
force that stops them from making
contact and we've become really
belligerent we keep throwing Spears and
shooting arrows at anything that
approaches our beaches but I have this
feeling that it up power exists
that is screening all contact and that
there's an entire world of people like
us and dissimilar from us who want to
contact us and you say oh really you
think there's like a federation that
really cares about us and stops us from
being contacted and they're tricksters
in the sense that they they prevent
Landings so that we will think that we
are isolated and alone in the world and
you know I'm trying to describe India
and you're making fun of the fact that
I'm trying to describe to India I don't
have the word India because I've never
spoken a word of Hindi or I don't know
that I'm probably an Indian citizen
according to the world but North
Sentinel Island has one of these
problems which is it's got effectively a
an unseen Force called India that acts
in some sense as a trickster to make
sure that they're not in good copernican
position to be able to observe the world
and
here I've got Mick West
talking about this in terms of what
sounds ridiculous because it is
ridiculous and the answer is no it's not
ridiculous at all no it's not but if I
was on north central island I would be
pointing out all the evidence that we
have for this thing yeah we see
contrails from jets flying overhead we
see boats uh occasionally people come
and they land on the island and there's
trouble so we've got a lot of evidence
that uh these these things actually
exist you know if they if they were in a
completely isolated island in the middle
of the ocean and they were hypothesizing
about something with no evidence and
that would be a different thing see it's
all about the evidence they they have
evidence on North Sentinel Island for
that hypothesis that you prepare and I
believe that we have evidence both for
and against
active visitation by intelligent life
that we do not perceive as any of our
own civilization not very good evidence
they have very good evidence on north
central island because they can actually
see people they can actually see things
like planes they can see boats you know
very often in in science experiments
I've watched people throw out the
outliers because they have a feeling
that you're allowed to throw out the
outliers and sometimes the outliers are
bad pieces of information uh this occurs
in you know the Tau Theta puzzle story
that Richard Feynman tells about the
asymmetry of the weak force and
sometimes
you know sometimes it's real information
sometimes it's an artifact of the
environmental setup what I what Outlaws
you think of being thrown out to the UFO
sphere
what outliers do you think of being
thrown out to the UFO speed we don't
have like amazing videos that are just
being thrown out because they're
well I think you and I are disagreeing
about something more fundamental
my feeling is is that
there's a sort of debunking energy
versus a scientific energy and I kind of
like debunking to be honest when it's
your great aunts
Poltergeist in her second home you know
there's a story about a kid who
committed suicide in 1913 and and now
haunts the house
I don't want to have to deal with that
stuff scientifically I don't have to
write an NSF Grant and and get the
University of Puget Sound involved or
whatever it
there's a role for debunking and then
there's the problem of the debunkers and
I think we have to actually talk about
debunking kind of an anti-social
negative movement I wanted
sorry let me I think that's ridiculous
though I think that's frankly I think
it's ridiculous because you know I I
identify as a debunker uh you know I've
said there are problems with that term
so unless you're talking about somebody
else I assume you're talking about me no
no no I'm talking about
there's a movement of people right all
right so do you see me as being part of
that movement well you've been curious
in my mind you're certainly and again
I'm I'm not angling for anything in
particular I'm not a takedown artist I
don't love interpersonal conflict it
feels to me
like
in the world of debunkers and I've now
met them in multiple Fields you are one
of the most disciplined and to be honest
one of the most charitable
that I've met
now so this isn't principally about Mick
West
the problem that I have with this as a
movement first of all skepticism doesn't
pay very well I've talked to Michael
schurmer about this
um it's very hard to to do the yeoman's
work of skepticism and make it
entertaining
so the problem with most of the skeptic
movement is that you start off trying to
say look I'm just trying to keep the
crap out of science so that we can have
a conversation it's not always
cluttered with somebody's ghost stories
or whatnot okay so that's very important
particularly with respect to religion
religion always wants to intrude
then you get into this problem which is
you have to spice up your skepticism
because it's not really tremendously
entertaining so that's when you
typically get snark you get
condescension you get stigma
and all of those things tend to chase
good people
out of these discussions much the way
good people are chased out of politics
there's an idea that politics belongs to
people who don't mind having five
private investigators scurrying about
over their life to interview every ex
boyfriend or girlfriend uh you know to
dig up any dirt to be printed on the
front page of the New York Times my
feeling about this is a lot of us who
would like to run for office like to see
other people run for office they're very
angry that the political crowd is taking
this over and it's like if you can't
stand the heat get out of the kitchen
well the same thing is true with UFOs my
feeling is I want to hear from a lot
more people
and one of the things that I want no I
want to hear from a lot more people and
one of the things that I want them to
know is that there are smart caring
people
who as long as they're not telling some
BS story and as long as they're willing
to reconsider their views don't need to
be debunked because that's stigma is
antithetical to agree antithetical to
science well just be careful what you
agreed to because I don't want to know
it's uh it still sounds good so far the
implications why don't you recapitulate
what Eric said so that we can see if
there is indeed agreement
well um yeah I think Eric is saying
essentially that
um there's a certain type of
criticism of various fields and we're
talking about UFO in particular here uh
the type of criticism that is identified
as the debunking community that has a
stifling effect like a negative effect
um the uh the chilling effect
uh which prevents discussion because
people feel like they're being attacked
they feel like they're being ridiculed
people don't like that a lot of people
are involved uh are deeply emotional
connection to it and so they're not
going to come forward if they feel that
they are going to be ridiculed and and I
agree that that is a problem and I think
you know in a broader sense it's been a
problem at the government level uh in
the the historically the government is
basically completely ignored the the UFO
problem the UFO issue if you look at
what the FAA was doing say even just 10
years ago uh they basically said call
this paranormal hotline it was a UFO
hotline but it still went to a site
which also dealt with with ghosts and
things like that so there has been this
kind of ridicule of the issue and I
really don't think that you know I or
indeed most Skeptics uh who actually
look into UFOs are really part of that
type of ridicule we actually investigate
cases in great depth we we do the math
we do the work we sometimes go out and
do the field work we do Recreation
experiments we try to figure things out
I've interviewed lots of eyewitnesses
and I do it with the greatest respects
and I trust that what they are telling
me is what they believe to be true so I
I would really welcome people to come
forward with with evidence why would you
trust that I would imagine that some of
those people are not to be trusted in
their attention trustees might simply my
default position I usually assume from
the start that people are going to tell
the truth because that's been my
experience that most people do now that
has Bernie in in the past a little bit
uh like people will will you know do
overtures to you and then they'll turn
around but most of the time you catch
more flies with honey I'm not going to
catch flies is probably a poor analogy
but it's uh I I I'm a naturally a nice
guy I when I talk to people you know I
emphasize with them and I understand
that you know it's it's a difficult
thing to talk about
uh so well let me ask you a question
I don't have the sense that there's any
real reason for any animosity between
you and myself to be honest at all no
why do I have the takeaway of what are
you doing in my timeline again
in other words
I would imagine
that in a slightly different world
Universe a prime rather than a where we
live you and I would be naturally Allied
on this topic
and yeah we're scientists scientific
type people who have a natural
skepticism of things okay so I didn't
come looking for you and then multiple
times you've sort of
entered in and you know you're talking
in specific about Lou Elizondo and
somebody who I think I've never
mentioned the name Chris Mellon I hope
I'm that it's yeah Chris melon can't
remember everybody's name is a
government official who's a part of the
whole invisible College type thing okay
so why
what is it that you perceive me as doing
that needs to be sort of minded
well you uh make bold declarative
statements about this you know this is a
huge deal I believe this is the thing
where it started to interact with you
that you thought it was like a huge deal
that either there are some kind of you
know advanced technology flying around
that we don't know what it is or there's
some kind of uh big you know cluster
starting with Harry Reid yeah I can't
remember exactly what you said but I
think you you were something along those
lines and I think at the time I was
basically saying what I am saying now
that it is you know more complicated
than that and the reason I I interacted
with you and I probably wouldn't with
just some random person is that you have
reach yeah you've got a lot of followers
you've got a very popular podcast you
you've written you've written books you
know you're quite well known and people
take what you said and you become a hero
within the UFO community and they listen
to what you said so I feel it needs
addressing Eric's written a book
I haven't gotten the coffee
it's a secret invisible book
um but sorry okay didn't mean to so so
Mick
I stand by my statement this is a huge
big deal and I don't mean this UFOs I
mean this decision tree has no boring
branch
yeah I I'm actually kind of in a little
way coming around a little bit more to
that than I was at the time when I first
disagreed with you first of all I really
appreciate you saying that
yeah well it's uh it's not not in a
Victory lap kind of a way just in terms
of evolution yeah I have no problem
changing my opinion when new data
arrives you just watched a clip from the
theories of everything channel for the
full video and all its magnificence then
click here and if you'd like to see more
then subscribe enjoy